lady white am i alive you are a toy you
belong to Bonnie these are your friends
woody I have a question um well actually
not just one I have all the questions
who wants to go on a road trip you need
help with that no no I got it
I know this is a little strange but we
all have to make sure nothing happens to
four key buzz we gotta get quite Roger
that
[Music]
change of plans Jesse ham but Bo Rex
potato hey watch it buddy
let's go save us pork do I need to be
worried my guys were better and so hang
in there
[Music]
No
I know the perfect toy to help
[Music]
do kaboom Canada's greatest stuff man
oh yeah yeah hold on one more oh yeah
I've known that guy my whole life
today's
[Music]
is that how we look on the inside
there's so much body needs fortune Oh
sheriff would you always come in to the
rescue
that's gonna be quite a jump for you and
do for me
[Music]
let's kaboom
Porky's being capped how do we get that
key what about the old plush rush there
you go Oh where did you two come from
well we're not doing that
[Music]